today on the Matt Walsh show Stanford
publishes an extensive list of benign
everyday terms that are now considered
offensive meanwhile a Canadian
organization puts out an activity book
to explain assisted suicide to Children
how are these two issues related I'll
explain also zolenski gets a hero's
welcome as he visits the United States
to beg for more money of course and
parents at an all ages drag show attempt
to explain why they're choosing to
expose their children to sexually
explicit content their answers are not
exactly convincing we'll talk about all
that and more today on the Matt Walsh
show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
if you're someone who has always wanted
to read and understand the Bible but
you're not sure where to start then
check out the Bible in a year podcast
from Ascension the Bible in your podcast
is currently the most popular religion
podcast in the US millions of people
have listened to it and twice it's hit
the number one spot on Apple podcast in
the Bible in the year father Mike
Schmitz reads the entire Bible in
365 365 daily episodes providing helpful
commentary reflection and prayer along
the way what better way to start the new
year you can find the Bible in a year
with father Mike Schmitz for free and
your favorite podcast app or on YouTube
plus you can follow along with a special
reading plan to help you better
understand the story unlike any other
Bible podcast Bible New Year follows a
special reading plan that organizes the
books of the Bible in a way that helps
listeners understand the story get this
reading plan at ascensionpress.com Walsh
if you want to start reading and more
importantly understanding the Bible this
year go to ascensionpress.com Welsh to
download the reading plan for free
that's ascensionpress.com Walsh to
download the reading plan for free
so you've probably heard about the new
harmful language policy at Stanford
University much has already been said
about it but as usual I think that
people are missing the most important
point so first if you aren't familiar
Let's uh get you up to speed Breitbart
reports quote Stanford University
published a list of words and phrases
deemed harmful language the school plans
to eliminate this language from its
websites and computer code and also
suggested words and phrases to serve as
Replacements Stanford's I.T Department
recently launched its elimination of
harmful language initiative which is a
multi-phase multi-year project to
address harmful language in I.T at
Stanford the goal of the elimination of
harmful language initiative is to
eliminate many forms of harmful language
including racist violent and biased
disability bias ethnic bias ethnic slurs
gender bias implicit bisexual bias
language in Stanford website and code
the guide reads uh of course the guide
is largely made up of perfectly
acceptable language used by Americans
for example it advises readers to say
U.S citizen instead of American because
of how harmful that term is before
listing the harmful words and The
Replacements the university issued a
trigger warning but even the term
trigger warning has been deemed harmful
so the school instead used its
replacement content warning and it says
content warning this website contains
language that is offensive or harmful
please engage with this website at your
own pace from there the so-called
harmful language was broken up into 10
different categories ableist ageism
colonialism culturally appropriative
gender-based imprecise language
institutionalized racism person first
violent and additional considerations
so those are the all the categories now
I read through the entire report making
sure to Pace myself as I was warned it
took me about 18 hours because I had to
keep stopping for mental health breaks I
broke out into uncontrollable sobs at
least a dozen times it was a deeply
traumatic experience but it was
necessary and it was educational because
you have to do the work and there are
hundreds of bandless uh words on this
list I think it goes up to a thousand
words or something and we can't go
through them all but
we can highlight just a few so under the
ableist category we're told right off
the top that addict is unacceptable it's
suggested that instead we use person
with a substance use disorder and the
reason is that as it explains you should
use person first language this is also
why person of color is acceptable but
colored person is considered unthinkably
racist it's likewise uh you know
recommended that you should not say gay
person but rather person of gayness
I mean that last one I made up but
that's the implications here other
ableist terms include basket case which
is a term offensive to both
crazy people and basket Weavers I guess
not to mention baskets themselves blind
study is no good but because it furthers
an ableist culture to say blind study
instead you should use masked study
though I imagine that next year's
Edition will rule out masked study
because it marginalizes people who wear
masks obviously
um and we should not say crazy crippled
handicapped lame insane mentally ill or
OCD
on that last one it suggested that
instead of saying OCD we say
detail-oriented
so example sentence Bob has locked
himself inside his bathroom for 17 hours
and is delusionally muttering to himself
as he washes his hands over and over
again until they bleed because he
suffers from
being detail-oriented
and this is only a partial sample of the
ableism category and that's just the
ableism category as we move on to ageism
we are commanded to stop saying senile
and said it's recommended that we just
use his name Joe Biden in the
colonialism category we're informed much
to the surprise of everyone in the world
that the term Philippine Islands is
racist
and we should consider just saying
Philippines instead
apparently the Philippine islands are I
don't know self-conscious about being
Islands having a bit of an inferiority
complex because they're excluded from
the main content and I don't know and
this is why it's best we don't call
attention to it I'm not exactly sure
then there is culturally appropriative
language like Brave
Guru Chief tribe obviously there's
gender-based language we shouldn't say
like ballsy guys ladies mailman man
hours man-made there's institutionalized
racism language like black hat black
mark black bald
I guess that's gender-based and racist
grandfathered uppity none of those are
any good and then they're just
miscellaneous words that are offensive
for reasons that can't possibly be
explained like convict immigrant
prisoner disabled person
all of these words and terms are no
longer acceptable according to our
cultural overlords and the words and
terms that we are assigned to replace
them with will become in short order
unacceptable as well
we must keep up to date on the language
rules follow the instructions and not
because the instructions make sense but
simply because they are the instructions
it's like a giant game of Simon Says
and that leads to
the point that is often uh missed this
kind of over-the-top speech policing
actually it has very little to do with
being sensitive this is the mistake that
conservatives have always made still
make
we're told that the term Philippine
islands has become arbitrarily offensive
and we say something like geez people
are so sensitive these days
but it's got nothing to do with being
sensitive nobody is actually offended or
hurt by any of the words on this list
nobody really cares this is about
exercising power it's about control for
control's sake
it's really not it's kind of like the
linguistic version of that scene in Cool
Hand Luke where Paul Newman's character
is forced to um dig a ditch for no
reason and then once it's dig they tell
Doug they have to they tell me that he
has to fill it back in again for no
reason
so the ditch itself serves no purpose
but that is its purpose by forcing
someone to do something totally
pointless and arbitrary you are
controlling them and you are controlling
them in the most humiliating and
demoralizing way
Paul Newman knew that there was no
reason to dig the ditch the prison
guards knew it everyone involved knew
that it was pointless and yet he had to
do it anyway it was a way of breaking
his Spirit crushing his Defiance
bringing him bringing him in line
and that is why
they do this obsessive language policing
that's what it's all about
but it serves a deeper purpose too of
course uh yes it's arbitrary no there's
no reason why one term is suddenly
considered offensive while another is
appropriate no there is absolutely no
meaningful distinction between the band
phrase disabled person and the
recommended phrase person with a
disability and yet
through the force of sheer repetition
the the person who abides by the
language rules
will eventually begin to perceive
reality in a way that conforms with the
rules
most obvious example of this of course
is the is the pronouns
it is as already covered demoralized and
humiliating degrading
to be forced to play along with
someone's gender charade by using their
quote preferred pronoun although the
term for preferred pronoun by the way is
also now not allowed that was on the
band word list you're not supposed to
say preferred you just call them
pronouns because it's not a preference
right it's not a mere preference this is
like this is what someone is in their
inner self anyway that's um that's all
true and and and that demoralization
that humiliation that degradation
is a big part of the point
but if if that's all the left ever got
out of it they'd be happy they're
degrading you demoralizing you
controlling you that's good but they get
more than that the person who follows
the rules at first reluctantly and
begrudgingly
will often eventually begin to
experience a change in perception as he
degrades himself
so too does his ability to perceive
objective reality become degraded as
well so by controlling words the left is
also controlling Minds in fact Michael
Knowles wrote a book on that subject as
you may have heard him mention a time or
two
so this week I think provides us
we have this example from Stanford
this is another example though it's far
darker and not nearly as funny not funny
at all in fact
um as you've heard on the show Canada
has recently set out to become the
suicide capital of the globe their
medical assistance and dying program
made as they call it casts a wide net
opening assisted suicide up to almost
anyone whether they're terminally ill or
not eventually whether they're adults or
not anyone can get it and if you want to
see how language is manipulated to
change the way people perceive reality
you can find no example more Stark more
disturbing than with the propaganda that
it surrounds and and promotes this made
program
case in point there's an organization
called Canadian virtual hospice and
they've published an activity book as
they call it an activity book
about suicide
aimed at kids
now aesthetically the activity book
looks like any other kids activity book
with a kind of childish font and lots of
illustrations and so on in saner times
you know this would be you see an
activity book like this it would be an
activity book teaching kids about the
solar system or dinosaurs or something
like that instead in this case in our
dystopia it's teaching them all about
the wonders of suicide
but it's the language that is the most
relevant for our purposes So reading
from the pamphlet
it says this
the term made is short for medical
assistance and dying the word medical
means the science of medicine and
assistance means help so made means that
medicine is used to help someone with
their death a doctor or nurse
practitioner a nurse with special
training uses medicines to stop the
person's body from working when their
body stops working the person dies this
is done in a way that does not hurt the
person the medicine helps them feel
comfortable and peaceful a person has to
ask for maid and then goes through a
bunch of steps before it can happen
what are those steps well next it lays
out the steps that are used to uh to
actually kill the patient and it says
this
in the activity book for children
the three medicines work like this the
first medicine makes the person feel
very relaxed and fall asleep they may
yawn or snore or mumble the second
medicine causes a coma a coma looks like
sleep but it's much deeper than regular
sleep the person will not wake up or be
bothered by noise or touch
the third medicine makes the person's
lungs stop breathing and then their
heart stops beating because of the coma
the person does not notice this
happening and does not hurt
when their heart and lungs stop working
their body dies it will not start
working again
this often happens in just a few minutes
but sometimes rarely it can take hours
notice the words being used here most
notably medicine
the person is not being given a toxic
substance meant to kill them he is being
given medicine
of course in truth this is the opposite
of medicine medicine by definition is
something meant to cure treat heal a
person's body
a substance which directly and
intentionally kills the person is not
medicine it is anti-medicine it is
literally poison doctors are poisoning
patients that's what's happening
even if you're deluded enough to support
this barbarity you should be honest
about it you should support it honestly
you should speak honestly about it
you don't support doctors giving
medicine you support doctors giving
lethal doses of poison to their patients
that's what you support
but to speak truthfully about it
is to perceive it truthfully
and that is precisely what the death
cultists do not want
it's what they wish to avoid at all
costs
because we're not supposed to see
anything for what it is
everything has to be cloaked in
euphemism
everything has to be shrouded under a
layer of misleading jargon otherwise
known as lies and the jargon has to
change constantly to keep people on
their toes
very few people would go along with the
left's agenda if they saw it and
understood it for what it actually is
so they cannot be allowed to see it and
understand it for what it is
that is what this is really all about
now let's get to our five headlines
if we're going to change the culture and
the dominance of large corporations that
actively work to quiet our beliefs we
need to reassess our spending habits and
start supporting like-minded companies
that's why you need to switch to the
pro-life Pro family cell phone company
Charity mobile Charity mobile has the
same great Nationwide phone service and
coverage of other carriers and they send
five percent of your monthly plan price
to the pro-life pro-family charity of
your choice you don't have to compromise
on on value or service Charity mobile
offers the latest phones and tablets and
Live customer service based in the US
the midterm elections made it clear that
the right for the right the fight for
the right to life will continue for
unborn children pro-life causes then
needs or continued support now more than
ever charity mobiles special Christmas
promotion includes a free phone free
activation free shipping and a free
portable battery charger for new
customers while supplies last just
mention promo code Walsh call
1-877-474-360
to or chat with them online at
charitymobile.com and mention offer code
Walsh that's charitymobile.com and
mention code Walsh
all right uh first of all uh thank you
to the ladies in the wardrobe department
for my Christmas I'm not wearing a
Christmas sweater but I'm wearing my
Christmas gift
from them uh you know instead which is I
don't even know if you'd see it on
camera I don't think you can but it's my
it's a UFO uh sweater and a sweater with
a UFO on it and I think that it was
supposed to be some sort of gag gift I
don't know but I I mean uh this is not
the first time this has happened to me
that someone gives a gift that's
supposed to be a gag but it's like
unironically I think it's great and I'll
wear the sweater all the time
um
Let's uh start with something that I
wish was a gag the president of Ukraine
zielinski visited the United States
yesterday it was a time of a great
excitement for DC and for the media
though not for anyone else in the
country like no one else is excited
about it but they're excited about it
um all of the zelenski worship most of
it anyway is is is relegated to those
areas DC media
um zolenski started the trip with a with
a a visit to the White House where he
expressed his appreciation
to the American people for all the money
that we've given him all the billions of
dollars he appreciates it isn't that
nice let's watch some of that
thank you so much Mr President of course
thanks my boss doesn't support thanks
Congress and and thanks from our walk
just
Ordinary People to your ordinary
people
Americans I really appreciate I think
it's very difficult to to understand
what does it mean when we say appreciate
but
but you really have have to feel it and
thank you so much great honor to be here
and yesterday I was on the bus in
Buffalo that is the place all these for
our country you know it all the details
we had so many phones that's good isn't
that very cute you're so appreciative by
the way can the guy put a damn suit on
like can you can you wear a suit for the
I mean I
I'm not saying that Joe Biden himself is
uh worthy of any kind of special
recognition like that but you're
visiting the United States you claim to
be so appreciative for it you are going
to the White House the later he would
speak in front of Congress
spoke in front of Congress without a
suit on
wearing a sweatshirt
and you can't claim so usually when you
when you see this he's doing all the
interviews and he's always got a t-shirt
or sweater on a sweatshirt on what we're
told is well he's in the middle of
fighting award he doesn't have time to
worry about okay well but yeah you flew
on a plane over here I'm sure you had
time to change into a suit and it really
is it it it it it really tells you
something like that that is a statement
if you go to the White House and then
speak in front of Congress and you can't
even take the time to put a tie on that
is a statement
and what is the statement exactly
there's a statement of disrespect
if you if you really if you're really
grateful then the the first thing that
you would do is think about how you're
presenting yourself how about how about
uh put that gratitude on display
um
but he doesn't do that here
although he claims that he appreciates
the help yet he was here to beg for more
help
beg for more money which led to his
state of the Ukraine address in front of
Congress uh post-millennial has a report
on that the Congressional chamber was
abuzz with excitement on Wednesday
evening in anticipation of Ukrainian
president voldemir of lensky's
zelenski's addressing the body to ask
Congress to make good on President
Biden's promise to deliver another 45
billion dollars in funding to assist
their war effort against neighboring
Russia zelenski was treated to
uproarious Applause from Congress as he
took his place behind the podium to
address the senators and representatives
some members held up a Ukrainian flag
and zielinski could barely get started
with his ask for cash due to the extreme
adulation showered upon Him by American
delegates he declined to wear a suit and
stood before Congress in a sweatshirt
sweatshirt house Speaker Nancy Pelosi
presided over Congress along with vice
president Camilla Harris as they looked
on with Glee at the coming of zelenski
who Pelosi had likened to World War II
era uh British prime minister Winston
Churchill
Pelosi silenced the room then presented
zelinsky for a second time to additional
cheering and they were cheering and
cheering I was really excited uh and
again they were they were there were
some members that were flying Ukraine
Flags
inside the halls of Congress
and zolonski went on to thank Congress
for spending American taxpayer dollars
to fund his War before saying is it
enough no not really Congress chuckled
appreciating his ask for even more US
Dollars and weapons uh we have that
moment actually let's watch the clip
so so here is the front line The Tyranny
which has no lack of Cruelty against the
lives of free people and your support is
crucial not just to stand in such fight
but to get to the turning point to win
on the battlefield
we have artillery yes
thank you
we have it is it enough honestly not
really
to ensure
embarkment is not just a stronghold that
holds back the Russian army but for the
Russian army to completely pull out more
cannons and shells are needed if so just
like the Battle of Saratoga the fight
for bakmud will change the trajectory of
our war for independence and for freedom
if your Patriots
stop
the Russian Terror against our cities it
will let Ukrainian Petros
work to the full to defend our freedom
[Applause]
um
Ukrainian Patriots want to defend their
freedom and somehow that's our job and
our responsibility they ended of course
more applause applause applause people
were excited and at the end he snuck a
little kiss with Nancy Pelosi I think we
have that moment uh let's watch that
wonderful moment here
I suppose there's no non-awkward way to
kiss Nancy Pelosi but
if such a way existed he certainly
didn't find it there was a quite awkward
and then he he gifted a flag to uh Nancy
Pelosi and Camilla Harris that I guess
they can split maybe cut the hat flag in
half about that
we put the flag in a shredder and give
little pieces of it to everybody so you
can have a piece of the fight but it was
signed I don't know who signed it I
guess I don't know some ukrainians
signed the flag uh which which is by the
way is like uh not that I care if you
choose to desecrate your own flag but
that that is flag desecration just like
signing the actual flag itself
okay now look
as far as zielinski goes
if I were in charge
maybe I'd welcome into him into the
country and then arrest him on suspicion
of war crimes potentially
because are we really just moving on
from the fact that the ukrainians fired
fired a missile into Poland a few weeks
ago killed two people
and then claimed it was sent by Russia
in order to hoax Western governments
into a global nuclear war
and we just like forgotten about that
and if the only way out of that
I mean it's a fact that Ukraine we have
there are facts on the ground here fact
is missile was launched killed two
people in Poland that's a fact fact uh
Ukraine blamed Russia for it immediately
and then used that
as another argument for Western
governments getting involved
and uh so and then and then another fact
is that actually turns out that the
missile was sent by Ukraine
the only speculation here is whether
they fired the missile intentionally
as a false flag operation
or if this was all some kind of mistake
that they then blamed on Russia
no matter how you slice it it does not
look good for zielinski and no matter
how you slice it he was using this false
claim to try to get America involved in
a war that would kill millions of people
of our people
so that that incident alone is enough
reason to not celebrate this guy as a
hero
but that's not even the point for me yes
Ukraine is actively trying to get us
involved in a world of war that will
kill millions of our people yes that's
true yes zielinski is as he's been
described essentially International
Welfare Queen at this point begging us
constantly for money and receiving it
billions of dollars
while our own people suffer
our economy is in shambles okay our
infrastructure is crumbling our border
is wide open we're in bad shape
and we're taking food off of the table
of of our of you know off of our
children's plates
and handing it to this corrupt foreign
government
our our cities look like
and basically are now refugee camps
people sleeping in tents
we've got these makeshift Shanty towns
in the middle of the street in major
American cities made out of cardboard
fentanyl zombies staggering around
we got kids graduating high school they
can't even read and and we're sending
money to one of the most corrupt
governments in the world in Ukraine
like we have the funds for that
like we can afford to worry about that
so yeah all that's true and all that's
awful but even if it wasn't okay even if
Ukraine was a wonderful country with an
honest and trustworthy government and uh
and zielinski was was as let's say
zelenski was as saintly a figure as they
paint him to be
that would still change nothing about my
perspective of the situation
and my perspective has always been
the same from day one
that this is not our our fight
now you remember when this all started
months and months ago
I was willing to admit I think I'm
probably one of the few people in media
one of the few commentators or pundits
that admitted from the beginning I don't
know very much about this situation okay
I before all this happened I spent maybe
a cumulative amount of like one minute
of my life thinking about Ukraine's
existence if that
now I'm because I'm focused on issues in
America I'm not thinking about Ukraine
I'm not worried about Ukraine
um
and what led up to this conflict and
everything going on behind the scenes
and all that but I I really don't know
which is true of 99.9 of this people in
this country and 99.9 of the pundits and
commentators
it's just that most people in that class
won't admit it like as soon as something
happens they all become experts on the
subject
hoping that the audience will never stop
to ask them like when did you
with you've never talked about this
before when did you become an expert
exactly
so I said from the beginning I I don't
know anything about this
so
as I said from the beginning
like
if if it will if if this is actually
important to average Americans okay if
the outcome of this fight
could have some direct immediate
quantifiable impact on average Americans
such an impact that we need to worry
about this or even get involved by
sending money or or Manpower
then explain it to me
what effect does this have on us why
should we care from my perspective this
is not our fight it's not our country
I don't see why we should care
but if you're someone who's hanging you
put a Ukraine flag in your bio and all
this kind of stuff and you think that we
should care that that that that average
American families ought to care about
what's happened in Ukraine go ahead and
make your case why should we care how
does this affect us
and they've had months and months to
explain it and they can't
because the answer is it doesn't affect
us that's the answer the most they can
do right basically there are two talking
points that that uh hope to justify why
Americans should be spending billions
and sending billions and billions of
dollars there potentially getting
involved militarily
as many people in our country or at
least in in the governing class have
called for
two arguments that I've heard these are
the only two arguments
um one
is the utterly Fantastical absurd
speculation that Putin that this is just
the first phase in a in a potential war
of uh of uh you know Global conquest and
that Putin's gonna move on from Ukraine
and then start invading more countries
and next thing you know he's gonna be
invading France and it's gonna be World
War II all over again so that that's the
first clip
that obviously was absurd from the
beginning and it hasn't happened okay
Putin is not gonna he's not gonna be
We're Not Gonna See Russian uh no
ships landing on our Shores they're not
that's not happening just isn't
so if that's not happening then the only
other justification we ever hear is just
this kind of vague uh we have to protect
freedom and this is the Ukraine they're
being invaded it's like all these kind
of vague sort of ambiguous uh ideas
about freedom and just sort of what's
these are good people that are being
victims
well if that's all you got then
only once again for the umpteenth time
confirms my immediate instinctive
reaction to this which is it's not our
fight
um
there are
you know someone sent to me on Twitter
yesterday they said uh well
and I've heard this a lot you know
Russia is invading Ukraine and uh and
it's happening whether you like it or
not
you got to pick a side it's happening we
have to pick a side
do we why do we have to pick a side
there are
con they're bloody conflicts happening
all over the world every day
you pick a side in all those
but what about all of the uh Wars of
conquest and and conflicts and
um all that sort of thing happening in
the across the entire continent of
Africa
every single day groups of people
warring against each other trying
fighting over land and all the resources
and all the rest of it
are we picking aside in all those do you
even know about most of those could you
even tell me
what could you even describe what's
happening there no
this is happening all over the world and
yet this one particular and no one says
we should pick a side
in most of those yeah and this one
particular conflict we have to pick a
side
why do you think that you think that
because the TV told you to that's why
it's because the TV is because the media
has selected this one conflict that
could have selected any they selected
this one and said this is the one that
you care about and then a lot of
unthinking Americans said well then I
care about that one
and they never stopped to ask why that
one
if Ukraine cannot defend itself
and preserve its own existence
then it won't exist
that's just countries have to be able to
to to uh live and die
of their own volition at a certain point
That's the Law of you know that's that's
the the law of the Jungle that's that's
the way we like it or not that's the way
it goes if you want to exist as a
country you have to be able to defend
yourself in your own interests
um all right
what else do we have here okay so here's
a story uh
it's from the post-millennial and other
outlets are reported to 18 age girls
have been charged with second-degree
murder in connection with the death of a
59 year old Toronto man according to the
Toronto police services the teen swarmed
the man and stabbed him multiple times
before fleeing a scene
he was rushed to the hospital passed
away as a result of his injuries the
incident took place just around midnight
on Sunday December 18th in Toronto
downtown Toronto the girls hear the ages
of these girls
three thirteen-year-olds three 14 year
olds and two 16 year olds were located
nearby and promptly arrested
so
um
I you know I and and we still don't know
exactly what precipitated this or what
exactly was but
a group of girls teenage girls kids
swarm this guy and stabbed him to death
and I bring this up because it's it's
another example of a point I try to make
often on this show which is that we
you know we hear so much about hate
crimes
but we don't have a hate crime problem
in this country or Canada in this case
culturally there isn't a hate crime
problem there isn't there is an
indifferent crime problem and and this
yet again is that
here you've got a bunch of teen girls a
bunch of kids swarming and stabbing a
man to death
what were their surface level
motivations I mean we don't know
but underneath it
um I would not call it hate
most likely
this this is the case for so much of the
brutality in the inner city the
brutality gripping our communities also
it's the case for many of the mass
shootings that we see
with these kinds of culprits it's almost
like hatred would be a step up hatred is
because hatred is human it's emotional
it's passionate is yeah there's if
somebody is hateful there's like
something you can work with there
um a hateful person feels something at
least he feels the wrong things
and he does the wrong things with those
feelings but uh there's something there
that's not what we see these days out in
the streets
what we see these days are people who
just feel nothing at all they have no
Humanity no really no motivation
violence for the sake of violence
just the real crisis is a is a a lack of
human conscience
um and it has reached a real crisis
level level especially in the cities
it's a kind of Lord of the Flies
situation
and we know
just as in that story when kids are left
alone on an island without any guidance
from their parents
they turn into Savages
as a fallen species savagery savagery is
what you descend into so we need strong
families strict discipline clear
guidance
uh you know a foundation of of faith and
moral uh formation in order to grow
Beyond those impulses and develop into
decent civilized adults
we need we our consciences need to be
formed
but that's not happening in so many of
these communities and this is the uh the
result
all right
let's do something a little bit less
serious here it's a controversy with
slightly smaller Stakes
so this video has gone viral it's a
video of a uh Karen
and that's how it's labeled anyway
that's what that's what and this is one
of the most popular genres of videos on
social media are this supposed you know
quote-unquote Karen videos and uh it's a
video of a Karen a white woman being put
in her place allegedly uh getting her
come up comeuppance
and for those not watching the the video
podcast this is what the video shows it
shows this woman this alleged Karen in a
confrontation with a neighbor in her
apartment complex through through and
this conversation is happening through
the ring doorbell camera
he never comes to the door to actually
talk to her but he confronts her because
she apparently was messing with his
welcome mat he had a welcome man outside
of his door but it had a profanity on it
apparently had the f word from what I
read it was like it said f off I think
big block letters and she didn't like
that so she flipped the the mat over so
that the words weren't seen he's very
upset about that and it led to uh this
exchange which will watch a quick piece
of that
excuse me ma'am
can you pick up can you pick my Rook
back up because I saw that you flipped
it over early it was not bothering you
or anyone
sir I don't think it's appropriate it
does not matter leave here this is a
it does not matter what you deem
appropriate
nobody else has said anything about it
does not give you the right to touch
anything on my damn porch you go up
there and tell your goddamn husband to
come see me when I come home
I'll be home at 5 30 make sure you out
make sure you're there ma'am so you come
down and talk
take your shake ass upstairs
so do you want to talk to me again
foreign
look I'm not trying to be ugly and I'm
not trying to cause any scene with you
whatsoever we live in a family
environment here I have children here
too to me having the F word on your
doormat is not
respectful of anyone that lives here and
it's not respectful of you to touch my
property it's not bothering anybody and
I have my neighbors across the hall
waiting for your mat I will pay you for
your map but get that out of here I
don't know what made you change it to
something so ugly as that but I I'm not
gonna no no
okay that's good that's fine and then
then he starts insulting her all right
so first of all this woman has not
done or said anything that deserves to
be labeled Karen
uh and that's why you know I as you know
I just I hate that term because Karen is
it is simply a racist smear against
white women that that is what it is and
so if you're one of those people that
goes around using the term
um
just stop using it like that that is
that is the the etymology of this slur
it's where it comes from it's originally
a slur by black people on social media
to uh smear and make fun of white women
that's where it comes from that's what
it is it is a racial slurp and it is and
now it's at a point where it's just like
if you're a white woman between the ages
of 40 and 80 then you automatically you
automatically fall into that guy and
anything you do if you get if you God
forbid get upset about something you're
automatically a Karen and it's I I you
know I I don't my mom is in that
category of being a woman between those
ages a white woman and so I'm actually
not okay with with hating an entire
demographic of people like this and I I
don't quite understand why people just
accept that
um and because we all know that if we
started referring to black women with a
stereotypical name
okay if I saw a video of an angry black
woman
and said like
oh this Shaniqua over there if I said
that it would be judged horrifically
racist
and yet this is okay and I I'm just done
with that we got to be done with that
this this this double standard that we
allow to exist
and you got a bunch of hen packed
cowardly white people who go along with
it so it's not the same thing at all yes
it is it's a slur against you have some
damn self-respect
now second
any reasonable person knows that you are
wrong if you go out of your way to put a
sign with huge profanities on it uh
right where kids are walking around uh
that there's there's no good reason to
do that there's no justification for it
but some people are saying well she
should have handled it differently she
should have gone to the property manager
or whatever
fine but I wouldn't have if that was me
I would have picked up I would have
picked the the the mat up now I would
have thrown it away is what I would have
done even if it's not my property you
can say that's not your property I don't
care that it's not my property because
you know why
I'm F I'm fine with people taking
matters into their own hands like this
because people are sick of this they're
just sick of it
this is a this is this is a good warning
for all of uh anyone out there who
thinks it's fun to be just an obnoxious
jerk with no class and no dignity and no
decorum and no sense of of basic
responsibility you know to to for the
fact that you're an adult in society and
there are kids around everything is
vulgar now right everything it's just
everything's vulgar and ugly and and our
kids are exposed to it and it's
everywhere and I can see where this
woman's coming from it just you see this
thing this stuff everywhere and now this
guy this freaking guy has decided to put
it on his welcome mat why
can we get a break from it like can I
walk down the hallway in the apartment
complex without seeing this stuff
people are tired of it
they're sick of it
and they should be
okay and they're not gonna because I
will go through the proper channels you
go to the proper channels and nothing
happens
you know that the the the guy there in
in the apartment clearly it's a black
guy you know uh
go go to the if she's a white woman so
it's all automatically there's the
racial Dynamic and she goes and she goes
to property manager and then and then
you know who knows the next thing I'm
going to tell it's like well your your
concerns don't matter because now
there's the the
competition of of identity demographics
here and
you know so people don't want to go
through the proper channels anymore
taking matters into their own hands
I saw a video this is it's not a recent
video I think it was from a few months
ago the guy uh
on a plane
with a big with a sweater that said uh f
f Biden on it but actually said the word
you know the f word in big block letters
and he was and they were in the video
they're trying to throw him off the
plane
um because they've got policy against
having it's not about you know it's not
about defending Biden you know I'm not
going to do that but it's just it's the
vulgarity it's the profanity and they've
got a policies this is their private
property you can't walk in here with
with huge uh profanities on your
clothing
but even that there's the people on the
internet are defending it removed Free
Speech rights oh shut up
how about just a basic level of of
decency is is all is being asked for
and I'm telling you people are sick of
it
you walk around like that you know
you're you're lucky if you just get
thrown out eventually people are gonna
you're gonna you're gonna get a punch
right in the face of what's gonna happen
because people are so tired of it
especially parents
Fed Up
to get this ugliness and this vulgarity
everywhere all the time and we are sick
of it
and these people that are just they they
feel like they're they're not
responsible to anyone they do whatever I
want
so
she's totally in the right here okay
that was not five headlines I think it
was like three but even so we're gonna
move on now to the comment section
[Music]
if you're listening to this show odds
are that you put a lot of stock into how
you raise your kids you understand that
your children look to you to Define
their values and their perspectives of
the world that's why it's extremely
important that you have a will in place
a will also determines how you uh how
your financial assets are dispersed as
well as your personal property it lays
out your health care power of attorney
to ensure that your end of life
decisions are carried out if you're just
starting out you don't have thousands of
dollars to spend on an attorney but you
want to make sure that your savings your
belongings and your family are all
protected you have to create your will
epicwill.com today epic Wills early
estate plans started just 119 bucks and
you can save 10 percent when you use
promo code Walsh so go to epicwill.com
use promo code Walsh to save 10 on Epic
Wheels complete will package that's
epicwill.com promo code Welsh
trust me says a pro upper post of
nothing it just dawned on me this
morning that the plural of Walsh is
Waltz maybe this knowledge will inspire
the Sweet Daddy to finally dance for us
what that's not
no that's not the plural of all shall be
what Walsh is what are you talking about
um
Jordan L says Matt definitely plays on
the floor with Legos and Star Wars
action figures after all his kids go to
bed
uh I I you know
I I I'll play with those toys with my
kids we've never actually been a big
Lego house
um which uh
no I think it's one of the more
wholesome and constructive toys that a
kid can play with but my kids have never
gotten into it that much actually
um Stephen says Matt I agree with your
stance on big Pharma but long covet is
very real I'm an engineering student
over the last year I've noticed a severe
decline in my health and subsequently my
academic performance after having had
coveted twice I'm tired constantly I
can't get through my day sometimes
falling asleep at my desk for up to
three times a day my resting heart rate
sometimes resting heart rate on average
is in the mid 90s and Peaks at about 180
when I go upstairs the worst the most
frustrating symptom for me is the is in
fact the brain fog I can't think clearly
enough to do math that I've been able to
do since fifth grade I can't keep more
than two numbers in my head at the same
time a trip over words I jumble them
around so much so that my friends notice
and make fun of me for it I feel like
I've become Joe Biden they've run every
test on me possible from every blood
test out there to an MRI of my brain an
ultra scan and monitor my heart and they
haven't been able to find anything out
of the ordinary besides the possibility
of long covet I don't know what to do
about it but my doctor has been giving
me a medication to help with the fatigue
but I'm still struggling greatly with
the brain fog it's the most frustrating
experience but perhaps in my entire life
I'll be a young life
um
interested to hear your thoughts SPG for
life well okay I'll give you my thoughts
and look I'm not saying
that what you're experiencing is not
real okay obviously you're experiencing
that and it's a real thing but
and can I sit here and
certainly rule out with with absolute
certainty the possibility that it's tied
to having head covered I can't do that
but what I can say is that like what
you're describing there are
literally
dozens of plausible reasons why you
could be experiencing all of that
um in fact they're not yet but there are
dozens of plausible reasons why anyone
in society would be experiencing the
things that you're experiencing
can't focus on things can't keep a train
of thought for very long feeling kind of
foggy tired all that this is just this
isn't these are experiences that are
increasing in society in general even
before covid
and part of the reason is that we that's
that's the world we live in now I mean
we live in a world how much time do you
spend staring at screens every day
we live in an over-stimulated over
saturated society and uh it makes it so
people can't focus on things for as long
as they used to it robs us of our
attention like we need this constant
stimulation otherwise we get bored and
start falling asleep and you know
feeling foggy not being able to
concentrate on things
so that's that's just like the general
uh environment that we're all living in
now
so is that
the 100 explanation for what you're
going through I can't say that but I do
know that it's that's certainly a factor
um
that's one of the reasons you know in
ADHD the other thing is a lot of what
you describe
also gets labeled ADHD which is why now
at least from that one study they want
to start treating long-coveted quote
unquote with ADHD medicine
that's one of my medical many criticisms
of ADHD when you hear people say well I
can't I can't focus on anything
I'm so distracted
well gee I wonder why that is we when we
live in a we live in a culture that is
designed to distract you every second of
the day we are all surrounded by
distractions every second of the day you
carry distraction around with you on
your person right in in the form of your
phone so you you literally carry a
distraction device around with you we
all do
and then we sit here and say I don't
know why I'm so distracted
this is just to illustrate the point
that there are so many factors and what
you're talking about is is so although
it's real it's also so kind of vague and
generalized that uh
to point to any one explanation like
well you had covet to me it seems like
there's there's no way that they could
prove that connection
and they haven't and so it's just kind
of a
an assumption maybe it has something to
do with the factory code how exactly how
is it that having coveted would then
cause you
so if you're if you're distracted right
now and you had coveted nine and a half
months ago
and they want to say well the covet is
what caused that how did it cause it
what's the mechanism
by which coven nine and a half months
ago can still be making you distracted
today they can't explain that
so it is at Best in Assumption
and I think it's an assumption I think
it's an assumption that we should be
skeptical about
until and if they can present hard
evidence and proof and say Yes covid
causes this here's how it does it we've
proved it here it is
until they do that
I would be skeptical
um
Mike says Matt as a hater of all things
that other people like that's not
entirely fair just most things I assume
you will agree that Christmas story is
overrated yes I absolutely will not
agree with that I I could not disagree
more in fact I think Christmas story is
rated
exactly as it should be
um I think it's uh for my money you know
it's some people say It's a Wonderful
Life is in the running for this and I
could see that but Christmas story is
the best Christmas movie
it is uh it is it is re-watchable you
know and it just it it it's a it's a
great Simple Story
um
and it's funny it's amusing it's all
these kind of different things
and that's all true but it also has it
just has this this quality to it that
it's it's it's kind of hard to describe
I think that that's the case also with
really good Christmas songs and there
hasn't been a good Christmas song made
in like 30 years if not longer
they made a lot of different Christmas
songs
but you hear all the modern ones you
hear any Christmas song that somebody
some pop star made two years ago and you
hear it and you're like yeah
it just doesn't have that Christmas feel
to it I can't really explain it but it's
not there for this
um
same is true for a lot of Christmas
movies but Christmas story has that feel
has That Christmas Feeling
and so I've I've seen I've probably seen
it 50 times and I enjoy it every single
time so you're wrong sir and
you're a band from the show
finally Skye says you truly are a
crusader on porn Matt I don't really get
it I can't get that worked up about
adults looking at porn online no pun
intended as a man many years your senior
I remember when you had to uh when we
had to fight for years just to be able
to look at a naked woman in the magazine
it was a battle that lasted for decades
it's very very Valiant battle sir
you're fighting for decades to look at
naked women in a magazine
do you ever think about just like
getting married
um I don't see throwing my that freedom
away because uh it because it it offends
the sensibilities of some people like
you if you don't like it don't look at
it I don't think children should see it
either but in a free Society there are a
lot of bad things taking away the
freedoms is not an answer you know sir I
don't even know where to begin here
first of all what freedoms am I talking
about taking away here now it's true
that that as I happily admit I am in
favor of just getting rid of all
pornography Banning it outright I
absolutely reject the claim that
pornography is Free Speech it is not
speech you know having sex with someone
on camera is not speech whether or not
you're saying something while you do it
it is not speech there's no like message
or opinion you're expressing it is
prostitution it's sex for money that's
what it is
but
that's not what we were talking about
this week was it we were talking about
uh putting basic parameters in place to
protect kids from it we were talking
about you know age verification for
websites so what freedom is being taken
away is it your is that you so what what
Freedom describe so your your freedom
your right your rights
to look at and have access to an
unlimited supply of free pornography
that doesn't require you to verify your
age that's your right where do you get
this right is what is this a is this a
god-given right is this embedded in in
your soul from birth is that what you
what are you talking about
is does it take away your freedom when
you have to show your ID when you before
you buy a bottle of whiskey at the
liquor store
does that take away your freedom
you know if you you have to produce age
verification to gamble at a casino or
online is that does that take my
freedoms are under assault they're
taking away my freedom
does that take away freedom
you know if you want to go buy a cigar
a 13 year old can't go into the cigar
shop and buy a cigar
are you going to show up to the cigar
shop with the with picket signs stop
robbing us of our freedoms
no you're not it's just with this it's
it's with this one particular thing
that it's in a it's an egregious assault
on your freedom if there are any
parameters put in place at all
it's like we this would require almost
nothing of you all it would require it
require like
however however long it takes you now to
access Internet pornography
if we put these things in place it would
take you I don't know an additional
seven seconds
but you're not willing to spend that
seven seconds just for the sake of
protecting kids yeah children shouldn't
see it but I children should see it but
I will do absolutely not one single
solid thing to make sure that they can't
that's what you're saying
very uh
very Noble of you sir
you're a band from the show too
whenever I get into a spat with someone
on Twitter over something I supposedly
tweet it it's usually because they
didn't actually read what I wrote
reading is a lost art on Twitter it's a
lost art across the entire country these
days but that's not the case on daily
wire plus Ben Shapiro's book club is
back tonight at 8 p.m uh 7 P.M Central
exclusively on daily wire plus this
month's book is the screw tape Letters
by C.S Lewis Great Book of course you
can tune in to hear Ben discuss the
novel and share his notes with you you
got to be an all access member to join
in though if you want to join the fun
head to dailywire.com Walsh to become a
member today and join Ben Shapiro's book
club tonight that's dailywire.com Walsh
now let's get to our daily cancellation
foreign
nicely in keeping with one of the major
and most unfortunate themes of the year
if the final daily cancellation of the
year was dedicated to the groomers in
fact because I'm a fair person today
we're going to give the groomers a
hearing we are going to let them defend
themselves we are going to listen to
whatever arguments they might be able to
put forward in their own defense
um I have long believed that it's not
possible for us to make a more
compelling case against leftism then the
leftist makes himself against himself if
you simply let him speak that was the
idea behind my film what is a woman and
today we will apply it to this
specifically to the suddenly quite
common phenomenon of the all ages drag
show last week we told you about the all
ages drag show in Texas covered by a
journalist named Taylor Hansen
it was a Christmas themed show which is
currently touring the country and which
includes graphic talk about sex graphic
performances of simulated sex uh
half-naked and nearly fully naked men
parading in front of the crowd
cross-dressing men with fake breasts Etc
it is graphic it's sexual it's obscene
and it's advertisers to all ages
how can it possibly be defended
Well it can't obviously but the left is
giving it their best try as typified by
this Twitter thread from an a so-called
investigative journalist named Stephen
monocelli
it's very important to Stephen
apparently that he defend the honor of
half-naked cross-dressers who perform
simulated sex acts in front of
Elementary schoolers very important to
him he's very passionate
about allowing these sorts of displays
and he posted a lengthy Twitter thread
with that goal in mind let's read
through it
he says quote
right-wing activists working with the
Blaze TV and Texas family project must
have realized that protests outside of
drag shows which often feature sexual
language and are always outnumbered but
don't look great don't don't look great
so they've taken the tactic of filming
drag shows for Selective outrage Hanson
and Sarah Gonzalez from The Blaze are
happy to play fast and loose with the
facts Hanson claims the drag show that
is touring Texas right now is family
friendly their advertising doesn't say
that what it says is all ages welcome
this is not unlike an R-rated movie
here's another piece of info about the
show that's touring Texas right now
spotted by Parker malloya it explicitly
says it contains adult content
ah okay see you got us he got us these
aren't family friendly drag shows
they're all ages drag shows ha see that
changes everything
what exactly does it change
well it's not really clear in fact
Stephen in an attempt to defend the
sexual performances for children has
only has only somehow succeeded in
making them seem even worse than they
originally than we originally suspected
he thinks that it gets the drag show off
the hook to point out how it advertises
the fact that it has adult content
but because he's a creepy degenerate
himself he doesn't see the problem with
putting the phrases adult content and
all ages welcome on the same poster
the fact that they acknowledge upfront
that the event is sexual in nature and
yet still make sure to note how all ages
are welcome only makes the pedophilic
grooming nature of the whole Affair all
the more explicitly and horrifically
clear
because keep in mind something
the defense up until now
has been that drag shows aren't adult
oriented that's what they've been saying
now they admit that they are adult
oriented but that's okay
because it says adult oriented in all
ages on the poster what
so once again we go from that isn't
happening to it is happening and it's
good
this is always the process this is
always the trajectory every single time
Stephen Compares us to an R-rated movie
once again defending it in terms that
only prove the opposite of the point
that he's hoping to make also although
you you technically can bring a child to
an R-rated movie
nowhere on any R-rated movies poster or
in its promotional material will you
ever see the words all ages welcome
okay if the movie Eyes Wide Shut came
out in theaters tomorrow
and in all the previews it said all ages
welcome
we would agree that it's a major problem
and extremely creepy at a minimum
or maybe at this point we wouldn't agree
I don't know after all the other side of
this debate has now reached the point of
outright defending sexual performances
for children
but what about parents
yes the drag performers themselves
deserve all the scorn and contempt that
we can Heap on them but the parents who
actually bring their children to these
events deserve even more of it
how do they defend it how can they uh
you know what can they say for
themselves
well fortunately the aforementioned
Sarah Gonzalez who has been doing a lot
of great work and important work on this
issue was on the scene for this uh one
drag show in Texas and she asked the
parents themselves why they're bringing
their kids
and here's what they said
the question do you find this to be
age-appropriate for your children
yeah I mean I'm a little more
uh I'm not as conservative but I mean
really it's not any different than I
mean Disney and Disney date they have
similar things like it's really not that
far from it I had sex of my father's
boss
in My Father's Office very honestly like
I'm by positives
do you find this to be age-appropriate
for children do I find this to be
inappropriate yeah for my child yeah
hello are you reaching for my team are
you hungry do you mind me asking how old
she is she's 12 12. she's she knows
about sex and
she doesn't see sex yeah well I mean she
kind of sees simulated facts in the show
she goes to school she sees simulated
sex all the time
you know what I'm saying it's exposing
sex to them too young
honestly because there's there's like
this is a little bit more forward but
there's there's innuendo and all that
kind of stuff in Disney I mean Shrek I
mean they're talking about are you
compensating for something there's a lot
of things that they don't necessarily
get
[Music]
I mean it is sexualized but like I it's
it's it is what it is I just think it's
the stigma around it that's you know
which they don't care I've raised them
not to care the sigma around what around
um you know different sexualities you
know it's just that's not any different
than you know straight people
[Music]
another big riot
so you don't worry that this is like
ruining her innocence or anything no she
needs to know what's appropriate and
know when to
say no consent and what's appropriate
and what's not and how will she know
that if she doesn't see it in a
Safe Way
so her argument is that kids are going
to eventually be exposed to
cross-dressing fetishes who simulate
sodomy on each other anyway so it's best
to introduce them to it in a safe
environment
in other words according to her kids are
going to be sexually harassed and
sexually groomed so you might as well
facilitate their abuse yourself
if you were wondering what these parents
could possibly say for themselves what
defense they could possibly offer how
they could ever manage to justify their
parenting choices well now you know they
can't defend it they can't justify at
the job of a parent of course is to
fight tooth and nail to preserve your
child's innocence
protect their heart protect their soul
protect their minds
not feed them to the Lions intentionally
because you figure that they're going to
be consumed eventually anyway
these are parents who don't care about
protecting their children obviously to
them the most important thing is to
Signal their leftist Enlightenment to
the world
and what better way to do that than to
offer up your own to the LGBT groomers
putting your in putting their innocence
on the altar as a sacrifice
this is what they're really doing
only they won't say it out loud
that is why these parents and everyone
else involved ultimately claim the honor
of being the last people of 2022. to be
canceled
that'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you well no talk to you next year
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]